where can you meet up for the most
diabolical celebration of all time
that's right whataburger and now for a
limited time as part of our new
diabolical menu we're adding two 61 meat
patties to every big homie burger giving
you not one not two
but three times the all-american flavor
but we're not stopping there we're also
giving you even more ways to get
diabolical when you add our new ranch
chili queso to any burger sandwich or
salad turning up the heat on your
favorite bottaburger classics with a
movie caliente punch to the guts
and be sure to bring the whole family
down for a super surprise as heroes of
all ages can collect one of eight
diabolical toys in every little super
meal
wow black noir oh i got laser baby yeah
i got picante balls so don't wait get
diabolical with your friends and family
or just come by yourself there's always
someone waiting for you at bottaburger
hungry for something fresh
why wait catch all eight coming march
4th to a location near you
[Music]
you